now we can talk to the shadow chancellor
rachel reeves here in the studio uh good
to talk to you today um there's been a
certain amount of criticism of what the
challenge has done a lot of a lot of the
paper saying he hasn't gone far enough
but but isn't he right to be modest here
we really don't know what is coming down
down the lane do we
inflation could go as high as 10 percent
isn't it right to be holding something
back
here's
two key takeaways from the spring
statement yesterday the first of all is
that the tax burden is now the highest
since the 1940s
and even by the end of this parliament
with the cut in income tax seven out of
eight working people will be paying more
in taxes only one in eight would be
paying less
and this tax burden is really hitting
when the cost of living crisis reaches
its crescendo if you like
because we know inflation already 6.2
percent set to rise to close to nine
percent
this year
and
to be taking money out of people's
pockets
at this time goes against goes against
common sense it goes against all the
economic evidence and we're the only
major advanced economy that's taking
money out of people's pockets at a time
when you've got a cost of living crisis
and that's in terms of the increase in
in national insurance contributions but
but the chancellor will say that because
also more people are being
pushed into paying income tax because
the ban at which you start paying income
tax has been frozen and more people then
are being dragged into paying a higher
rate of income taxes as well because
usually that would go up with inflation
but the chancellor has chosen to froze
it so more and more people are paying
more and more in taxes at a time when
the bills are going up and up and up
something has to give and for many
people on low and modest incomes there's
nothing to give but even for people
working on modest salaries it is really
tough right now when petrol prices the
weekly food shop and most of all the gas
and electricity bills are just reaching
staggering levels it is tough and
there's no denying that but but the the
chance from the government would say
it's tough for reasons
out of outside of their control it's
tough because of covert it's tough
because of what's happening with the war
in ukraine and we haven't even seen the
full impact that that's going to have on
our energy prices these are things that
in all fairness the chancellor and the
government can't control
but chancellors have choices of who to
tax and who to shield and the chancellor
has chosen not to ask anything more from
north sea oil and gas companies i've
said that labor would have introduced a
one-off windfall tax on the big profits
being made by north sea oil and gas
companies right now you know the chief
executive of bp said that they've got
more money than they know what to do
with he described running the country
that it was like a cash machine right
now but the people paying out
are ordinary british families so let's
have a one-off win for tax and use that
money to expand the warm homes discount
so that the poorest and those on modest
incomes get some more help and also cut
vat on domestic gas and electricity
bills to give everybody a bit of money
off their bills right now that was the
sort of measure that i would have liked
to have seen in the spring statement
yesterday but there'll be critics who
will also say that that doesn't go far
enough if
if inflation is going up at these
extraordinary rates but incomes aren't
that's the disconnect i mean would the
labour party go further would the labour
party for example tie benefits to
inflation well so
the the the package we have announced on
energy prices would have taken up to 600
pounds off the bills of um of around a
third of people so it would have made a
big difference you know gas electricity
bills are going up by almost 700 pounds
we would have taken 600 pounds of
people's bills that is in far in excess
of anything that the chancellor has
announced and we could do that because
of that windfall tax you ask about the
situation of pensions and benefits now
of course they're supposed to go up in
line with inflation but the problem is
that that inflation rate that was chosen
was last september's inflation and since
then what's happened to inflation it
hasn't just crept up it's spiraling out
of control it's already twice that level
so we should go back to doing what is
supposed to happen which is pegging
benefits and pensions to inflation now
the fact is because inflation is so high
now and it is likely to be for the rest
of the year
next year pensions and benefits will go
up by more let's bring forward some of
that increase so it helps people right
now when they most need that support but
how far could you go i mean if inflation
goes up to ten percent would the labour
party
put benefits up ten percent i mean the
the bill
it's just eye watering because right now
inflation is six point two percent
next year when benefits go up the
benefit increase and the pension
increase will reflect the inflation that
we've experienced this year so pensions
and benefits will eventually get there
it's just too late to help people with
their bills now so what we're saying is
bring someone forward some of that
increase that will happen next year so
that people actually get the money in
their purses and wallets when they most
need it when bills are going up by 54
you know i've got pensions in my
constituency who are saying they don't
turn the heating on now even though
they're really cold because they can't
afford it i've got mums who are saying
i'm skipping meals because the most
important thing to me is my kids eat
properly people shouldn't be having to
make those impossible decisions but
because of a failure of the chancellor
to act yesterday more and more people
will be making those decisions one of
the things that he did announced
yesterday was the income tax cut and
cutting it from 20 to 19
in the future is that something you
oppose
look this chancellor says i believe in
lower taxes um but it's a bit like a kid
who plays um air guitar in his bedroom
and thinks he's a rock star you're not a
low tax chancellor if you're increasing
taxes but he is going to decrease them
they are going to go down from 20 to 19
that's a decrease by anybody's standards
but let's look at things in the round
because you can't just say that tax is
going down all of these are going up
overall by the end of this parliament
seven out of eight working people will
be paying more in tax only one in eight
will be paying less in taxes but
specifically on income tax do you
support it do you do you oppose it
if so why not i've been very clear that
i want to see lower taxes on ordinary
working people that's why labour would
not be doing this national insurance
hike uh now if this chancellor really
wants to help working people and keep
their taxes low he should have cancelled
that national insurance increase
yesterday i want to see lower taxes on
working people the chancellor should be
doing that now when people need it on
the specific tax of income tax going
down from 20 to 19
you're not going to oppose it are you
well look let's see what happens because
there's no finance bill it's not in
legislation you know the chancellor
promise of jam tomorrow is not going to
help people pay their bills now
it is all about it's a game for this
chancellor he's announcing a tax
increase just ahead of the next general
election because he's more concerned
about the electoral cycle than he is
about the inflation cycle and helping
people with the cost of living crisis
that is hitting now